today we're going to talk about modern
data management how to set up your data
for Success within your organization so
I'm Alec I'm lead business operations at
select star we're a data Discovery
platform uh we work with a lot of
different companies from five Tran block
Pitney bows Open Door fair to basically
help them manage their data model
working with both data Engineers data
platform teams data scientists Etc
so what are we going to cover today
we're going to talk about why we think
data Discovery is important I'm going to
blow through that section in the
interested time pretty quickly then
we're going to spend the bulk of the
time talking about rollout strategy so I
wish I could tell you you just buy a
data Discovery tool or a data catalog
and all of a sudden you're going to have
perfect data Discovery but there is
process that needs to be put in place
and so that's where we're going to spend
the majority of our time and how to do
that efficiently and quickly so that you
can get value right away from a tool
versus you know having a month-long
implementation process and then we'll
also cover some tips and tricks for
implementing the catalog
um so quickly you know we think there's
really three major Trends driving the
need for data Discovery growth of data
in the cloud uh decentralization of data
ownership you know embedded data teams
within different organizations creating
uh opportunities for misalignment
duplicative work etc and then also
democratization of data access with
modern bi tools now everyone can be a
data consumer a data Wrangler you know
people are are it's not just the data
team that is needs to understand where
your data is and what it means and so
that creates a lot of challenges for
organizations
um questions pop up where can I find
this data do we have it why are my
numbers different
um you know did we did we make a change
here Etc
um and they're they're really hard to
track down so when you think about
historically how people have gone about
answering these questions
um you know it's a slack blast where
it's not clear who should be responding
one-on-one messaging if you know who the
subject matter expert is
um and that is just internal knowledge
it's not being institutionalized or you
go and try and figure it out yourself uh
looking through GitHub or you know
sifting through query logs on your own
it's very manual process it takes hours
and hours of work and it's just not an
efficient way to go about it for an
organization with lots of data where
these questions pop up all the time from
different people often similar questions
um so existing Solutions we feel aren't
um necessarily adequate uh you've got
like Wiki documentation it's static it's
not connected to your data people who
have gone through this process by the
time they get everything documented in a
Google sheet it's already out of date
because your data model is dynamic it's
always changing and then you've got DIY
or open source solutions that require a
lot of engineering resources and time to
roll them out similarly with Enterprise
data catalogs powerful tools but takes a
lot of money a lot of time you know it's
going to be months potentially before
you're getting value from these tools
you need to hire full-time fdes to
manage them so we think there's a better
way which is with a modern data
Discovery platform like select star that
can automate a lot of this process help
you find understand document collaborate
and govern your data
um so that's kind of the Preamble but
what I really want to focus is rollout
strategy right you believe everything I
just said I want a data Discovery tool I
want to buy one but how do I actually
implement it so that my team can be
successful so that's what we're going to
walk through
um and I think the key thing when you're
getting started is to really understand
objective stakeholders and Milestones
right you need to know the why The Who
and the how for data Discovery so that
you kind of have a North star to make
sure that you're successful
um so the objectives need to be clear
from the start and you need to have some
amount of organizational buy-in whether
that's just for the data team or all the
way from the c-suite down to understand
why do we need this tool what are the
specific pain points we're trying to
solve what are the use cases we want
this tool to be leveraged for that's
going to make sure that this is
successful versus just another you know
SAS line item that no one actually uses
and just sits there next as part of that
is understanding who are the
stakeholders who's going to be
responsible for helping to do the
initial rollout who's going to be
helping to maintain it over time who's
going to be leveraging it using it you
want to have that really clearly
identified up front and then similarly
Milestones right like what are we trying
to do here how are we going to measure
success if that's a governance kpi so
amount of ownership documentation is it
reducing the burden on data teams are we
trying to reduce the amount of time they
spend triaging something or the number
of questions they're answering on an ad
hoc basis those are all things you want
to make sure that you're tracking and
measuring up front
so uh objectives differ based on every
organization some of the common ones we
see are maybe preventing data outages in
the organization so you want to make
sure that dashboards are up to date
they're accurate you don't have outages
and that people can actually trust the
data that they have
and so this might require being able to
really easily find lineage Trace
dependencies you might want to integrate
it with your CI pipeline to proactively
prevent outages and that will require
bringing in data engineers and data
analysts as part of that if you want to
enable self-service analytics to reduce
the bottleneck that a data team could be
when people are trying to make
data-driven decisions and allow them to
find their own data understand it and
then take action on it that's going to
bring in you know business stakeholders
and other folks so each of these
objectives has you know different
Milestones you want to track different
stake holders you want to engage so
being very clear from the start of this
is what we care about this is what we're
trying to do with this tool
um we'll just allow you to really plan
appropriately for who needs to be
involved in a data Discovery tool
rollout
um we typically look at deployment in
two phases the first phase is what we
generally call design and that is
leveraged mainly by the data platform
team and analytics engineering team as
well as uh analytics folks business
analysts sort of the power users who
really understand your data and then
phase two is the broader rollout where
you can bring on data consumers less
technical folks to leverage the platform
you know it could be Biz Ops PMS
operations managers or even c-suite
Executives who are just looking for a
dashboard and want to understand how are
we calculating our metrics
so phase one uh starts with the data
platform team and this is where we
design the data catalog so we look at
this across across a couple different
vectors first is we think uh tagging
structure is really important and select
star uses tags other tools use different
terms but it's really about how are we
classifying our data what are the
different domains we want to track what
are the different statuses we want to
notify people about uh you know lots of
companies may use the like bronze silver
gold level for their data in the data
warehouse to denote is it raw data is it
production data Etc so we asked the data
platform team to Think Through what they
want this design to look like we don't
require them to go and tag all of their
data because that's a lot of effort and
we're going to talk about that in a
moment but we think developing that
design up front is really critical so
that it's not the wild west when people
get into the tool and you've got a
thousand different tags some of which
may in the same thing
next is data deprecation so trying to
clean up your data model tools should
help you find data that isn't being used
and you might want to remove that from
the platform you may want to remove it
from your data warehouse or bi tool to
save on costs or you may just want to
limit the scope of what people can
actually see in the tool to what's going
to be relevant for them and then the
last part is ownership to help as you
start with curation when people do have
questions you want to have those subject
matter experts clearly defined hey I
need access to this data who's the owner
or I notice something's wrong who should
I notify you want to get those owners in
there
um and not all data is created equal so
you should start with the most important
data for your data model and get that
documented and curated and move on from
there you can roll out a tool with only
15 of your data documented because that
might be you know 85 percent of the
value to your company and like I said
tools like select star other data
Discovery platforms will make it very
easy for you to identify what's actually
being used what actually has
dependencies Downstream
uh phase two or sorry phase one part two
is bringing on those power users so
analytics and data science folks people
who live in the data or maybe subject
matter experts and they can help you
fill in the missing gaps in your
documentation when we think about
documentation we kind of break it down
into three groups first is automated
insights you shouldn't have to do
anything manual here your tool should
provide this automatically so that's
lineage it's popularity entity
relationship diagrams you know example
queries and joins these are things that
should come out of the box with a tool
it should be automated so your team
doesn't have to do that work next is
additional curation so this is around
adding those tags that we talked about
adding in any missing data dictionary
terms at a field or column level and for
every organization depending on your
data maturity you may already have this
the tool can ingest it automatically or
you may need to add this in and a tool
like select star or a data Discovery
platform can be really helpful for
crowdsourcing that information
because sometimes the developers the
engineers don't have all the business
contacts to properly document your data
for those end users
and then last is the semantic layer so
metrics business glossaries FAQs those
sort of things you should layer in as
well
after you get it your tools sort of
curated at least that you know the most
popular data sets then you want to
prepare for the broader rollout
um and we think there's kind of two
important steps here first is developing
Rules of Engagement for a platform so I
don't see a tag that I want
can I create that or should I ask
someone to do it a description is wrong
can I update that myself should I be
submitting a request
um you know I need access to this data
that I can see exist but I don't have it
what's the right path there so in order
to really
get involvement from folks in the
adoption of a tool you want to have
those rules clearly defined up front and
easily accessible so that people
understand how they should be engaging
with the platform
then the next is onboarding materials I
think this differs for everybody some
tools you know you may have really
intense training courses for select star
it's designed to be intuitive and I
think a lot of the modern tools are as
well so you know you might do a quick
product demo but what we really like to
do is set up how-to guides for common
workflows so for each Persona think
through how are they going to be
engaging with the tool and give them an
example and then data trivia is
something we've also seen be really
successful where you come up with actual
questions the data team has answered and
here's how you can do it in select star
you give them those questions and then
people submit their answers you know
we've seen brown bag lunches where
people share here's how I answered my
own data question with the data
Discovery platform and you know that
that just sort of helps to reinforce
that this is how you can be
self-sufficient with these sort of tools
um so as far as the the timeline goes
you know we think you you want to set up
your key milestones and track progress
um this is going to be different for
every organization but in our mind
platform setup should be really quick
um you know with select star it's
usually a day maybe two the catalog
design
um again it depends on your organization
how complex your data model is but the
design itself should be maybe one to two
weeks and then curation uh we don't have
a timeline to give here because it
depends your starting point some folks
already have all their data documented
in DBT you're good to go other folks you
know they don't have a data dictionary
to begin with and so that might take a
little more time but those are kind of
the key steps then you get to your
rollout you onboard your data consumers
and you want to start tracking the usage
of the platform to verify you know that
hey people are actually using this we're
getting Roi so key things like num
percentage of data assets that are
documented number of monthly active
users there's ownership
that's for usage of the platform but
that doesn't necessarily tell you Roi
because maybe someone's only in the tool
for two minutes but they were able to
answer their question really quickly so
we think that's uh very beneficial so
you also want to check in with your data
team and see how much time are you
spending on these tasks how many ad hoc
questions are you getting
um and things like that
um so I only have a minute left so I'm
just going to kind of buzz through these
tips and tricks
um first is with tags we think break
tags up into category tags for different
domains status tags to tell you more
information about that data
um docs and metrics we think are
important getting all of the
documentation into your data Discovery
platform linking it to data directly so
people can see here's my metric here's
where it lives in my data model here's
who else is using it or similarly
documentation for how is a table
generated process design things like
that should be linked directly to your
tables and then for user engagement we
talked about training for usage when
people do have questions inevitably
share links to them from uh from the
platform to kind of help them see oh I
could have answered this for myself and
then tracking the tool should do that
for you
um so that's it thank you guys uh
hopefully this was helpful if you have
any questions about data Discovery how
to roll out a data catalog or select
star you can find us on our website we
got a booth in the expo hall for the
rest of the day and yeah thanks
foreign